this is a Fox News weather alert
hurricane Irma is now a tropical storm
but that's not stopping the cyclone from
continuing to wreak havoc on the
southeast the storm battered Florida
yesterday first landing in the Florida
Keys as a category 4 storm before slowly
making its way northward over 12 million
Floridians are still without power and
over 1 million people in Georgia also
had no electricity today for more on the
story let's go to Steve Harrigan live in
Naples Florida Steve Kimberly giant
trees like this were just pulled out
from their roots by winds gusts of up to
142 miles per hour yesterday afternoon
in Naples it has been tough going for
the people here no electricity a very
dark quiet area they've been trying to
make their way through the streets
downed power lines down trees rescue
crews are trying to clear those streets
a lot of neighborhoods still flooded 12
inches of rain here during that storm as
well but the promised storm surge though
people were afraid of it could be 10 to
15 feet come up suddenly and kill people
that simply did not materialize the back
end of the storm just too weak to make
that happen so while there are roofs
down trees down power lines down some
serious destruction not devastating
destruction and most important no lives
lost in the storm in Naples the big
challenge now is electricity more than
200,000 people without it no AC a lot of
schools damaged as well so a lot of
families will be having some tough times
over the next few days as we wait to get
back to normal here in Naples Kimberly
back to you I thank you for that report
Steven we turn now to Rick Leventhal who
is on the ground in Daytona Beach hi
Rick hey Kimberly the storm dumped 8 to
12 inches of rain here in Volusia County
in a very short period of time flooding
countless streets and neighborhoods like
this one in low-lying areas and knocking
down trees and power lines leaving
hundreds of thousands of people in the
dark in this county alone but some of
the locals in the neighborhood just a
few miles from us in Ormond Beach say it
was a twister a tornado that did the
worst damage in this storm roaring
through like a freight train at about
9:00 9:30 last night splintering trees
and knocking down utility poles and
ripping roofs off of houses dropping
them in a
George and right in the middle of the
street we talked to some folks who were
hunkered down inside the Ormond Beach
Masonic Lodge nearby they thought they'd
be safe there instead the storms ripped
the roof a brand new roof off the
structure and the how the people inside
thinking that the end could be near was
sitting there playing Kozik the lights
flickered three times and it went dead
silent and then all of a sudden it felt
it sounded like a bomb going off he did
two to two tours in Vietnam three and I
asked him I said how close was that to
Nam just last night and he says ain't
going to get no closer to that there is
a countywide curfew in effect from 10:00
p.m. to 6:00 a.m. in part because of all
the debris in the road and the 150
traffic lights that were knocked out and
the cleanup is going to take some time
we shot some additional video on a
360-degree camera and you can see more
of that if you want you can log on to
the Fox News Facebook page at
facebook.com slash Fox News you can see
that 360-degree video and a lot more
stuff but again the situation here in in
Volusia County not great tonight they
got a lot of work ahead Kimberly all
right thanks Rick for that update and
let's go now to Mike Tobin who is live
in Tampa with a very latest Mike and
Kimberly never got as bad as people
feared here in Tampa the biggest
difficulty like some of the other areas
is power outages more than half the
population is without power the primary
causes debris things like trees hitting
the power lines crews were staged out of
harm's way but that meant they spent
that today driving work starts tomorrow
some communities are talking about weeks
till the power comes back on Tampa
Electric is saying it will be a matter
of days the primary source of damage out
here flooding and down trees lesli
Wilson never doubted the tree in her
front yard because it was so big until
it came crashing through the roof during
the middle of the hurricane last night
it trashed her husband's cars she said
she never liked that car anyway she's
glad no one was hurt the steeple at the
historic New Salem Baptist primitive
Church came off during the worst of the
storm last night the pastor Bishop
Benjamin curry thanks God that no one
was hurt and that says with the new hole
in the roof
you can see all the way to heaven
Kimberly my thank you for that update so
a lot of news that happened this weekend
and just you see the devastation and
what people had to deal with on a daily
basis very touch-and-go in terms of
whether or not they're going to be okay
their family members their loved ones or
children their homes everything that
they know and love that it was just
really kind of like minute by minute
trying to get the update they'll take
around the table and just get some of
your reflections Greg well one positive
thing that I went up when you see
something like this is the power of
decentralized government here you have
one of the largest evacuations we've
ever seen and the rest of the country
rolls on that's because the bottom-up
decentralized country something that can
happen here everything else is happening
here okay it would be total paralysis
and a top-down centralized socialist
country we know how to deal with these
things we can we can run our governments
and our military and capitalism all this
stuff while something like this that's a
good thing I am NOT going to miss all
the weatherman competing for who can
stay outside the longest and I'll tell
you why it's an unspeakable truth that
it looks like fun like when you were a
kid and there was a storm you wanted to
be outside and so you're watching this
and they're telling us to stay inside
stay out of harm's way yet every you
turned on every single channel and
there's a guy doing looks like he's
doing leg splits or K you know he's
stretching his abs and he's leaning in
like this and I'm just watching I'm
gonna like I get it I get it but this is
like like if I were a kid I go maybe I
will go outside I want them to send you
next time yeah no I'm just saying it
looks like fun and I don't know if
that's the message you want to send
right you want it to look like wet yoga
versus kids it was wet Pilates yeah
you're into that well well I think that
Governor Rick Scott in the in the mayor
of Miami and other cities demanding the
evacuation early right so that people
had enough time to get out with smart
they had a little bit of a problem with
the storm going for they thought it go
up the East Coast and West a lot of
people evacuated from the east to the
west and then they all try to get north
but it looks like this aside from the
debris which it will be tough to deal
with and heartbreaking for a lot of
people when they have to get home and
realize their possessions have to be
replaced but I do think that again local
government did a very good job they were
smart to demand
and I also saw today they're cautioning
people not to try to return home too
quickly because there are like one
there's no power I also heard there's no
power and no sewer so we know that got
salt but definitely not want to go back
home and that you wouldn't do well the
other thing I want to say is that we did
not have reporters for this particular
show in two places that were really hit
hard and maybe didn't expect it to be as
bad and that is in Jacksonville Florida
where they have record flooding and then
also just incredible flooding in
Charleston South Carolina which is sort
of used to it but it's so beautiful and
historic it's a shame that it has to
keep going through it well it just shows
you know the unpredictability of Mother
Nature and you try and anticipate and
prepare and that's one of the ways that
you you know stop and prevent some of
the damage that can happen to people's
homes or the loss of life and trying to
anticipate to try to out think you know
the storm but we've seen with the way
this has done change in its path and
pattern and trajectory like dana has
mentioned and other places that we
didn't weren't able to show tonight that
really got hit hard that weren't
anticipating it that's why it's so
dangerous when you underestimate a storm
like this you have a lot of naysayers
you're now looking at the TV oh it
started as a cat 550 mile an hour winds
now it's a tropical storm we all heard
about the catastrophic impact it was
going to have and then people turn on
the channel and they see flooding and
they see this and they say oh you know
the weather men overhyped it the media
oversold this but you know what
that's not true you want to be safe you
want to overhype it if you do believe
the stats show that it's going to be
catastrophic and look even if it wasn't
Armageddon there's horrible flooding and
the keys are totally devastated and
Jacksonville's still not out of the
woods yet so there's a real human
tragedy that's still unfolding right now
that people shouldn't be to flip with
the other thing is we heard the sound
bite of the guy saying he did three
tours of Vietnam and this is close to
Vietnam weather is war sometimes the
impact is very similar there's a similar
human toll there's a similar physical
toll it takes on the environment and
when governors like Scott or Governor
Abbott prepare for something like this
in a way you are preparing for war
because it's so unpredictable you want
to just make sure you have all the men
all the ass
in the right place because anything can
happen and it looks like the contingency
plan of the governor was perfect I'm not
saying there weren't mistakes made but
he erred on the side of caution and I
think he saved a lot of lives and now
the cleanup starts and it's going to
cost a lot of money well it's true and
you know it's not just ok the Hurricanes
got the winds to contend with you had
the record flooding like Dana mentioned
in Jacksonville and also in Charleston a
tremendous amount of damage
hums whan when you have that kind of the
heavy wind just ripping things apart and
the water I mean it's just what you just
really are always constantly reminded of
the strength and the power of the flow
of water that comes down from these
surges well I don't think there's any
question about Kimberly and the the
thing that strikes me is of course that
most people today are just giving thanks
to God that it wasn't worse and the
sense was that this was going to be a
devastating storms gonna wipe out things
and if you're in Miami that's not the
case there's some flooding but even as
we heard the surge did not appear in the
surge was what was you know he'll the
potential to you know take people off
reefs and to damage people and property
in ways that we can't anticipate cuz we
haven't see something like that I think
that one of the things that's important
to note here is that there is real
damage and real lives lost in the
Caribbean in much higher numbers where
the storm hit earlier places like st.
Martin's reportedly just devastated and
wiped away and you go to Barbuda and
some of these other so-called Lesser
Antilles and again damaged just
unbelievable behind the damage that's
going to impact them as we head towards
the holiday season when they make their
money but you come up the u.s. wet East
Coast and again it's not over because
what I'm hearing is that it goes now
into not only the Carolinas but
Tennessee potentially Alabama and that
these areas are not going to be hit with
heavy rainstorm so high rainfall that
could do tremendous damage you know a
lot of us and I guess it gets back to
what Greg was saying we watch on TV and
it's almost becomes like we're watching
storm porn you know things oh look at
that did you see that did you see that
well you know what at some point you got
to break away and say you know thank God
it didn't devastate a state with so many
people with such a large population of
elderly
very good points yes and we don't want
to forget about the people you know in
the Caribbean or whatnot that have been
very devastated impacted by this